2 c'est pas une stratégie c'est la
réalité d'un électorat qui s'est
constitué contre le pouvoir en blanc
seing de monsieur hollande contre la
politique gouvernementale contre la
politique européenne et qui est assez
logique
je trouve avec requiem c'est d'ailleurs
ce qu'on pouvait reprocher jusqu'à
présent aux gens qui votaient mélenchon
où il faisait des campagnes très très
viril on va dire à l'égard des
socialistes en général du parti
socialiste et de ses alliés mais
systématiquement d'aller second tour on
pouvait considérer qu'ils allaient à la
soupe en appela à voter deuxième au
deuxième tour le socialiste quelle que
soit la situation
là je dois dire c'est la première fois
que ça se passe et je trouve ça très
sain et très certainement ça aura des
conséquences sur la recomposition
politique avec vous avez salué la
dignité 1 de jean luc mélenchon soir du
premier tour là